demi lovato now she has also come out as  a believer in aliens and demi you had an  encounter before shooting the show can  you please give us the details on that  experience we went out into the desert  in joshua tree and i basically saw like  this blue orb that uh  was about 50 feet away  um maybe less and  it was just  it was kind of like floating above the  ground just like 10 or 15 feet but was  keeping its distance from me and i don't  know it just um it was really it was a  really beautiful and incredible  experience  yeah i think those might have been the  drugs that you were taking but no i  actually no i i beli listen  i believe you  demi lovato i believe you on this i hear  you  you are valid  and i i just i buy it  and i say that mostly unironically